and here are the three charts that
explain why Janet Yellen is raising
rates until December Ellen talk us
through your first one it's looking at
the labor markets conditions index we
seem to think hey labor markets are not
doing too poorly we're looking really
good what is this chart tell you well
this labor market conditions index sort
of wraps up those the broad number of
labor market indicators at Janet Yellen
always sites that she needs to see
improvement in it's not just about the
unemployment rate it's about the share
of part-time workers that wish they
could work full-time but can't
discouraged workers the the gambit and
it drops it all up into one neat index
and it did weaken in the later spring
months and that a lot of that was as way
digested some of the layoffs in the
mining sector because lower oil prices
led to layoffs their manufacturing
sector had a little bit of difficulties
because the rapid rise in the dollar
some of the production was slowed or
halted in certain areas so we had to
digest that in the labor market
conditions index declined now it's moved
back into positive territory so it is
growing but growing more slowly or it
means the labor market is improving but
improving more slowly this is critical
for the Fed because the entire way they
framed monetary policy and their desire
to lift rates is based on continued
improvement in the labor market so we
follow that monthly conditions index
closely to see that it stays in positive
territory and at least shows even if
slow improvement that it does continue
to improve all right you mentioned that
the dollar was one factor it was a drag
talk more about that we have a chart of
the dollar why is that something you're
paying close attention well I think we
can't harp enough on the dollar as a
wild card for the Fed not only a wild
card on when will they lift weights but
the dollar as a determinate on the pace
of rate hikes after they do start
raising rates they it causes a lot of
indigestion to central bankers when
their currencies have a rapid
appreciation or depreciation and what we
saw from our August through early March
was an unbelievably rapid ascent of the
u.s. dollar it can be extremely
disruptive and net trade was our biggest
drag on growth as a result in q4 and q1
so if the dollar continues to
as rapidly as a central banker I can't
have enough confidence in my outlook for
growth to raise rates today and so many
policymakers have said they hope that
the bulk of the adjustment has been
complete so the bulk of that rise was
markets adjusting leading up to the
first rate hike but we'll see if the
dollars appreciation remains tame then
the Fed can have the confidence to move
if as they get close to raising rates
the dollar takes off it's going to lead
to too much uncertainty and they'll
choose to delay and the last chart
really has to do with the savings rate
consumers cat stashing their cash and
not paying on spending talk to us about
this so starting with the April meeting
of the the Federal Open Market Committee
they spent a good deal of time talking
about why why why is the consumer not
spending and what we found is that
there's actually a lag time between the
time that gas prices bottom which they
did in January and the time that
households start spending that savings
because they have to be convinced that
gas prices not only have they see that
they've fallen they have to be convinced
they will stay low and it's about a six
month lag and so we are in that period
and we think consumers have started to
pick up their spending we've seen that
as i mentioned q2 spending tracking
two-point-nine percent versus 2.1 in the
first quarter so we think the consumers
are spending more the Fed will need to
see more data they'll need to see that
July retail sales report Joe that we'll
all be watching closely i do like yeah
july july july but that will tell them
if consumers are going to continue to
bring that personal savings rate down
and spend more